[Applause]
golden state starting curry
and uber in the backcourt with wiggins
green and looney
and the shot is down to get our scoring
start but he's doing a lot of that jim
he's rebounding and he's passing and
he's play making and
he always brings great defense to the
party as well as curry fires
and hits his third three and brad
stevens wants
a time out this is the second game of
four straight in texas they'll play two
against san antonio monday and tuesday
night
after the two here in dallas curry
trying to draw the foul count it and one
and curry with a chance for a four-point
play
third leading scorer on these mavericks
hold for two to start that's a three
steph curry with his second
three-pointer
curry way downtown bang steph curry from
just inside half court
from the alamo it's a three how about
that
right at the hash mark and he
understands that he understands what
teams are going to try to do against to
be physical look at the movement without
the ball
pops out for another three
yo splash works second chance points too
we'll be watching that
shot clock is off steph down to two
stops he backs all the way up oh no
oh that is almost unfair
the game has been broken this is a curry
bayless out here at two
steph with the three oh he beats the
buzzer and drops in
another triple and 30 for third
michael mulder kent bazemore checking in
they're doing it as a tandem
as steph hits another three and vucevic
the problem for them defensively is
vucevic doesn't want to get out to the
three-point line
he said draymond and four guards here he
backs up burch
[Applause]
look at him posing afterwards so he
passed it back out got better position
he's like okay now i can try to take
draymond that size
coming through staff for the step back
three
[Applause]
jetty osman hit a couple threes early
but mulder played him well there
final minute 17 of this first quarter
curry
and the heat check is in full effect
right now
yeah good job being aggressive turning
the corner off that pick and roll action
forcing the defense to help
you don't help makes them pay the price
curry working against none
lets the three go scores it steph
with a huge dagger gotta be ready to
guard him
steph curry joins the party with the
three
yeah a little handoff got it back shake
your head one team or another is going
to have a little sense of momentum
heading into halftime right now
the magic of time take control of the
game curry
can change that very quickly yeah evan
fournier knows better than that
but an eight-second game shot clock
difference steph thought about
the quick pull and there is the quick
pull for three
and he banks it in
steph to ubra but there's nerlins noel
and curry a little step back three
impossible for anyone else but just
routine for him
in the building right now one of the
other three is in the building oh very
good yeah
in the building nice here's curry with a
step back
it's good and a foul a four point chance
for steph curry
so to sum up that whole thing that you
were saying lebron james is pretty good
that's a good summation absolutely and
so is that guy steph
curry with uh and one three
talking to terry stotts earlier today he
raved about
the impact that gary tran has had on his
team as curry knocks down
uh-huh pull any stark on you having a
game of thrones i'm not ready for the
game of thrones action
zach levine step back
the beal is heavily involved here's
levine from
deep and he's three for three a lot of
dribbling tonight a lot of you know
guys holding on to the ball
this is against one of the worst
defensive teams in the league there's
levine with another three
that was a tough shot it is an 11-2
washington run to go back up by nine
points their first turnover
in this quarter
the wizards turn it over sadaransky out
to levine for
three i've seen you know for his size as
fat lever
oh nice call yeah oh what a shot
five to shoot levine has the space
oh give me just been a little bit of a
slog for him shooting
hasn't been for levine tonight
here's levine step back trying to guard
uh draw the foul on man and he's still
got it to go
okay that's that's crazy clippers
shooting 54
bulls shot 61 against the clippers in
the first game
first point to the second quarter for
levine he's got 13. bulls can go two for
one down the stretch
trailing by two holiday guarding levine
now sabonis
levine step back three for the lead oh
give it a shot by levine oh stop
it zach williams white carter temple and
levine only one starter for the pistons
out there now that's grant trying to
defend stop it he cannot do it there
oh man of double-digit point
performances
he's not been able to get the stroke
going tonight a lot of the bulls haven't
except for this guy
but this guy's got the stroke going zach
levine another
30 piece temple levine white and
williams back out there together
two point game two and a half to go
levine step back three
good let me step back and kiss myself
joel and beat is the reason why you were
in this game but in order to open it up
and
and have a chance of getting this win
somebody else is gonna have to start
knocking down
shots levine difficult look but not for
zach levine he's got a very fancy last
name
vanderbilt oh yes vanderbilt of the
kentucky vanderbilts
zach levine already in the double
figures in this opening period
levine late in the clock the pump the
three it's good oh
give me the hot sauce zach levine with a
pure
three first four of overtime rubio no
not gonna get the call that time bulls
have numbers levine
wide open that's a three give me the hot
sauce zach
sadaransky is in for colby white well
they've had so many injuries
exactly the same just like miami i mean
you lose paul millsap
there you go zach gafford comes out with
it so daniel gafford is going to get
time with some of the bigs of this
pelicans team
being as big as they are levine hits a
three
and look at lonzo ball just shaking his
head like wow
adam's back in for the pelicans
defending in the paint temple with a
tough shot
tipped alive to garrett temple out to
levine that's a three and it's good
at least thinking about in terms of mvp
conversation well it is
his success starts his numbers his
numbers warranted
yes right now his number's warranted and
that's the spot
[Music]
down two
johnson the throwing here's paul
alice hasn't fouled the game
finds cam three on the shot clock
deep three on the way from booker who
delivers
the bull's eye
the pelicans are playing really well and
i know the sun's up you know really
upset with themselves that they didn't
really be more accountable in that game
but
sons with time booker head down
barreling ahead
fires the three got it
it's played out pretty well though for
javel over the last few years
championship team three the last four
years as book
brings the boom put his head down
and become a malcontent stay ready and
now look at the production
as we said he is a pros pro as booker
looking inside fading to his right
kenmore 65 i mean okay
[Applause]
deandre's got to know if he just goes up
he's going to get fouled on that play
i mean you catch the ball right there
you got it because right now it forces
that guy to do that off jefferson
that's it you build that confidence you
can't build a skyscraper unless you
build a nice foundation
speaking of skyscrapers that's his
foundation right there
point forward for you so it's a lot of
good things that he can do
yeah he suffered kind of a freak hip
injury as they prepared for the bubble
is
booker look working on lillard step back
three on the way
cash it in
gordon haye was a very good rebounder
and he's a lot stronger than what you
think he just took that away from mchale
d3 on the way cash itch
in i mean he comes off of there you've
got to get up and
make him at least be aggressive buck
that's delicious yeah that's easy too by
the way
he's not going anywhere he's going to
get great minutes and he's got the ball
in his hand
and his team's in contention booker
leans in
draws the contact gets the bounce
and a look for the four-point play one
is not to be able to give up just
lay-ups to the rim if you're the celtics
but the celtics
the discipline behind the three-point
line i mean utah is going to come after
you
as you see jalen brown welcome back
o'neal chasing him
angles guessed right another three goes
back to back threes from the top of the
key and jaylen brown has all the points
on the board
the area he has to improve on is going
to run a lot of pick and rolls from the
top
brown keeping the dribble alive down to
two down to one
and banks home of three it's friday
night bank is open taking deposits
three goes that's another big shot
jalen brown when you're in a 2-3 zone
you've got to find those guys
brown looking to answer and does
remember brown was
five for five in the denver game in the
second half from three
i feel like it's 16 straight mike yeah
it's this thing
[Applause]
pass a little behind brown he's able to
track it down but they're down to seven
now
on the shot clock thompson comes running
out and sets the screen and
brown drills it you gotta love thompson
though
alley-oop doesn't work out sells again
in transition
brown pull up three oh man
three in a row jalen brown
feeling the heat pulls it back out to
walker for three
at the end of the shot clock no good and
tatum with the board in another
possession
brown three got it
[Applause]
tatum had his pocket picked by george
but it's scooped up
jalen brown from downtown getting to the
eight
open space good read
who's made three johnson goes for the
steal
brown that 7-3 wingspan
of kelly ubre that's his first miss of
the night though
and now tatum drills one over juan
tiscano anderson
especially when you're down a man
everybody has to contribute so good job
on the boards by golden state
jason tatum with the first bucket of the
second half you
tatum step side three oh he buried it
jason tatum has been a facilitator a
rebounder a defender hallie
trying to put a button on it i'm telling
you
two and a half to go tatum for the tie
got it jason tatum with poise and
precision
knocks it in yeah boston outscored them
richard 38 to 20
20 in the third period tatum had 12 and
he continues
on that torrid pace rookie pritchard
nearly forced the turnover shot clock
down at three
tatum eyes up has to take a tough
contested three over the top of bridges
and
well you just tip your cap there to
jason tatum
[Applause]
step back tatum
that's a great job defensively getting
deflections getting out and running they
don't wait for it to wait for guys
they're always
attacking off the catch it's a big part
of their offense
at
tatum off the bounce
williams looking immediately inside back
to tatum top of the key he'll take it
make it
tayden with that little side step of his
and buries the three
came off that screen and roll with the
switch had its rhythm
tatum step back three this time and that
sees nothing but the bottom of the net
tatum has a completely different bounce
to his step
tatum
[Music]
step back over galinari and he buries it
jason tatum has some type of rhythm
today
[Applause]
tatum step back over collins
knocks that down man that is a tough
tough shot
back in the day yeah no not even then
it'll just be disappointment nothing
disappointing about that
jason tatum going right with the step
back
tatum with the three got it oh how about
that dribble move to shake the defender
mark wipes his jersey taking on tatum
tatum for the tie yes
[Applause]
tatum step back three goes
i didn't know that mike well there you
go yeah
that's good once again you go home
richer than when you came
oh jason he didn't know he's right
[Applause]
tatum with three on the shot clock has
to take it
drains it oh
[Applause]
that's a big time shot tatum
six on the clock pull up three oh
man what a dagger up against the clock
hesitation dribble rises up teague
those are the ones tatum
and he spots up and connects
doing the little things rebounding play
making
getting open threes like this one
taking on plumley hangs on a pivot
clears back out front here's donovan
shot clock at seven mitchell fires a
three off the wing
oh flash at home donovan
20 for mitchell josh jackson finding a
nice game 15 points for him
who are the hawks going to go to to
create points you know without trae
young he handles the ball the majority
of the time offensively
defensively we've already talked about
how he's leading
front runner for rookie of the year he's
got talent
third pick of the draft mitchell step
back three wow
you cannot stay in front of donovan
mitchell he's too good you can't stay in
front of a jordan clarkson
because individually one-on-one they
will beat you more times than not
joe denied picked up royce reset it
here's donovan deep for three got it
dropped
at bankers life field house in
indianapolis donovan goes to work
steps pumps the shot is away and good
donovan mitchell in double digits
already in this quarter
so this is his 10th game of the season
and he has not
shot the ball well career low in field
goal percentage and another three down
donovan mitchell this time sticks one
for the utah jazz good note there on
gobert you try to find some defensive
metrics that help define what he is
third in the nba
contested twos here's mitchell he's
fouled and won get to where you're at
comfortable
pull up for a nice easy jump shot
utah another chance here here's mitchell
oh big shot for donovan mitchell back
when i was a player now if they would
have had the panel at the park avenue
mitchell there we go
butler with six first quarter points the
jazz find themselves down
seven donovan rides home of three first
bucket first three tossed in by utah oh
what page is that one that's a new
chapter four
he just amazes now he's gonna put up a
three and all of a sudden
donovan mitchell just like that
yeah shake milton's out
jazz roaring back a pair of threes off
the hand of jordan and now donovan
great defense conley with the help
[Music]
donovan crosses over paul george and
nails the j
beautiful bucket big time shot let's see
what happens
now they're fourth in three point
percentage here's mitchell catch and
shoot
it's a three it's a three-point game
let's see if they can get a steal
immediately bella ball is the real deal
he is absolutely the real deal
he's going to be a superstar in this
league for a long time to come
in your mind the front runner for rookie
of the year mitchell
wow falling out of bounds with a shot
clock winding down
hits that three 14 on the shot here's
clarkson
gives it up to donovan splashes home his
first shot
there it is over two to start this game
and a three ball down spiral hard work
there was time when you left him open he
didn't close out at all
now you've got to get out early on lonzo
ball and there's donovan mitchell utah
with a seven
second shot clock
[Music]
rudy needs help clears donovan takes on
tobias harris just beat the clock and
knocks home a three